first off we're gonna make the dough now
this dough takes a bit of time but it's
really exciting I'm heating all of the
milk with the sugar this yeast easy to
get hold off when you make fresh donuts
you need fresh yeast an exam of the warm
milk to the yeast will activate it which
will help the dough to rise just 1/2
give that a quick whisk the sugars
dissolved in the milk the fresh yeast
disintegrates instantly set the yeast
mixture to one side while it does its
job just now the main dough mix and
Manning half the butter to the remaining
milk that gives the dough a nice
silkiness I want it light so melt the
butter into the milk flour into a sieve
that helps to make the dough nice and
smooth and you know what when you got a
smooth dough it sort of Rises evenly add
a pinch of salt and two egg yolks
pouring the warm milk and melted butter
don't start over mixing it and you over
mix the dough of a doughnut it gets
really tight you don't know that it area
yeast in
nice and warm I love that smell now I'm
looking for a sort of elasticy texture
just dropping off the spoon nice flour
the board take the dough out lovely
lightly sprinkle touch more flour just
pull it over and push in may be time
you're sort of turning it almost like
you're turning the dough into itself the
dough should just sort of relax
I should be sticking to your fingers now
it's just nice and pliable set that in a
nice clean Bowl and we'll sprinkling
flour in there so as it starts to rise
just a stick cover that with sim from
leave the dough to rise in a warm place
for sixty to ninety minutes until it's
doubled in size this stage is called
proving now boss that's proving hella
panel for the chocolate filling or
ganache pour five hundred mils of double
cream into a saucepan and add honey
bring the mixture to a gentle boil
traditionally we always put jam in there
but chocolate and donuts
Wow to die for add the cream now give
that good mix the butter elevates the
ganache into a really nice shiny
chocolate coat that will give it a
really nice whisk the wissen gives it
that aerated texture to get a show just
lightening the load a little bit Wow
nice chocolate filling done put it in
the fridge to cool then it's time to
gently roll out the dough just let it
roll naturally that a centimeter and a
half in depth slice 1/2
place them on your tray and let them
rise again once the donors have had 30
to 40 minutes to rise it's time to
shallow find them in a pan filled 1/3
full with hot vegetable risen but look
they're sort of little pockets of air
right here we go place these in nice and
carefully for maximum if there's too
many in the pan the oil will go cold and
the donuts will come out soggy turn them
over peaceful
when I come out into some sugar mixed
with some malt powder 50/50 how do you
tell that actually cooked in the center
tap on top should be hollow in just
sprinkle the malt and the sugar shake
off the excess I get so excited every
time I make donuts now there's beauties
these are delicious eating as they are
the ganache is gonna be the icing on the
cake
piping bag peel the bag over your hands
don't forget pop the nozzle in I want
her texture almost like a little liquid
inside so I'm a pipe one with a little
bit warm hopefully where that bursts of
magic operation donor lift up the donor
squeeze push in and fill just do you
start seeing and chocolate coming out
sit that back down mmm
nice
sit them on there I've got a little bit
heavier we all know why nice
that one's got my name on it
that is amazing
add the curry paste and cook to release
the flavors add cube potatoes to serve
dollop the black bean mixture on crunchy
tortillas